cara allora che colore mettiamo oggi ma
facciamole come la volta scorsa ma
sempre allo stesso colore vuoi mettere
ma dai ma cambia un po su
semin attimo katia ma sarò libera di
scegliere cioè se io voglio mettere il
rosino news per tutta la tinta lo
mettono bene il mio colore preferito non
mi cacciano altrimenti non li voglio
mettere c'è allora godio te lo dico
subito homer devi fare più lunga troppo
corte ma ne fottono altre volte motivo
ora cioè riesco ancora a fare troppe
cose capito così voglio proprio capito
di un uomo riuscire ad accogliere le
cose quelle cose ha capito che dici wow
leung è lunga come colore e mail e file
motore riesce a fare così come una
maglia però sai cosa va bene leopardato
sul rosa però anche coi brillantini
capito ma non argentati orio guardami
bene secondo te io mi metterò mai uno di
questi colori per me esiste solo al nero
nera come la mia anima nero come il
periodo di inferno questo passato ma che
lunghi e voglio corte così corte che si
deve vedere la carne che si deve vedere
che me ne mangio non togliere la
pellicina mio passatempo preferito
tesoro come facciamo le unghie bel
problema perché ne ho tanti di coloro in
mente è difficile scegliere
ho scelto quel quel lancio né un po
ciliegia ecco quello di dai mi sa che
cambiati via perché ti spiego devo
andare un matrimonio e o un vestito
azzurrino quindi ho pensato che magari
lilla questo qui non ci sta meglio con
l'azzurro è meno mike mi ha fatto la
trama perché voglio cambiarlo quello lì
come il blue note più scuro bello quello
lì le voglio fare così si giura gran
caldo più vedere amore dai dove ti
chiamo grazie ciao
ma dava tutti i capelli tra le unghie ma
come è fatto da ilaria ti giuro che non
sono stata io ma che lo giuro ma ti pare
che mi mette le mani tra i capelli
mentre faccio lunghi poi cioè ceca che
non l'accetto guarda 60 euro di
ricostruzione dopo la settimana di cade
l'unghia ma ti giuro che non sono stata
io va bene cioè stata massimo la
lavatrice il frigo e tutte le cose che
sono venuti addosso la mia lunga c'è
guarda casi a tu mi credi ho passato un
periodo proprio guarda ma brutto così
sicuro però di lanciare mano però devo
dimorare hanno aspettato fine del
discorso sono certo gesticolare se non
mi capisci mi arrivò alla 8 e tra
l'altro giorno mi che lo vedo con una
che era quella dopo capi stava sulla
palla io allora sono rifatto e una detto
vi sono chiamati che non aspetta un
attimo katia lungo me fai dopo per la c
ho detto tu non mi rei di più ma neanche
in cartolina ballo ti prego ma a non
farmi ma non me lo merito
la lima no katia ti supplico un minuto
di pausa mi esce sangue vero o
disinfetta me se vedo il sangue muoio
marone ha un'anima questo è un
cacciavite cacchio